[Music]
hey
you guys yeah uh we just got a question
from just pepper who said uh do you guys
get paid if we don't skip the ads
i think i'd have to look it up but i
think even if you skip the ads
you get a little bit of money like a
penny or something like that
but i think you get a little bit more if
people watch the ads
yeah but i don't it doesn't really end
up mattering all that much why doesn't
add up too much
no it doesn't we do get ad revenue yeah
um every month i think ad revenue is
about about two to two hundred bucks a
month
something like that yeah so it kind of
adds up over time but
yeah but we have so many videos out
there working for us most of them are
like
the old videos yeah because i wanted
retroactively like monetized all the old
ones
although i don't have i don't put ads in
the middle because i don't like that and
it annoys me
but i put them at the beginning on the
end um you know and i make them all
skippable
some of our old videos have like [ __ ]
30 000 views on them
and then made money over time and it's
like the ed lorraine warren video
and we were kind of
evidently like the ed lorraine fans
didn't like what we said about them and
so it gets a lot of hits and a lot of
[ __ ] negative comments it's funny
if you if if people think you're an
[ __ ] you make more money
sometimes well yeah i mean if you're
going to get people like i said
that's not really i mean because my idea
but well
and the thing about my mindset too is
that if i if i start watching a video
and the dude seems annoying or an
[ __ ] or whatever i just click to
another video i don't like take the time
out of my life to like comment on it for
some reason that lorraine video gets
some negative comments but it gets a
[ __ ] ton of views and it makes a lot of
money
yeah it's not a lot of money it's just
that if you were to look at the fraction
i think that one that one some of the
old ones actually are out there
working pretty hard for us but we also
gain a lot of new subscribers off that
video
i mean it depends too because i think
sometimes it's like
well sometimes what i was going to say
was that a show that we did a long time
ago
like about a serial killer for example
and then like netflix or something puts
out a new documentary about it so people
will be like watching that kind of [ __ ]
because they're like newly interested in
the dude or whatever
it's just funny you never can't tell
nothing's nothing's planned
nothing about this channel is contrived
no
we're just doing it and then
sometimes it works out sometimes it
works out we don't ever mean to do
like oh hey i heard netflix was gonna
put out a thing about this hero killer
so let's do a show about it
literally every single time that that's
happened it's been a total complete
accident
yeah like i just it just so happened
that we did something about it and then
netflix decided they were gonna do one
the secret to this
channel's success if you want to call it
success i don't think it's success in
comparison to what it would have been a
long time ago
before of [ __ ] like the advanced
algorithms i think the show would have
we'd probably have a couple
hundred thousand views by now a couple
hundred thousand subscribers by now
but the the the secret the secret to our
successes is that we just wouldn't go
away
yeah the secret is we don't really have
a secret we just kind of do whatever we
feel like
most of the channels just go away over
time and we just keep doing it can't do
we forced people to deal with this
and like i said in a lot of ways our
shit's kind of like intuitive it's just
yeah you know and we don't even mean for
it to be intuitive i know it's a weird
thing to say but it's just kind of like
whatever movie we feel like doing
whatever
topic whatever whatever and it just ends
up working out most of the time
you know what i mean not always but and
uh interestingly how we saw this movie
was kind of like that too it was kind of
uh an interesting little kismet because
remember yesterday we talked about that
2014
kevin smith movie tusk right and david
june had sent us the blu-ray of that
now on the blu-ray there were a bunch of
other trailers
because i was actually not aware of this
but tusk
was distributed partially by a24 studios
so one of the trailers on
the beginning of tusk was from another
movie that was from a24
that was an australian movie called the
rover and then we saw the trailer and
tom's like
that looks really good because it looks
like a post-apocalyptic
i don't know if it's post-apocalyptic or
it's more like dystopian i guess you
would call it more dystopian than
post-apocalyptic i don't think there's
been a nuclear war or anything like that
well they said it was 10 years after the
collapse i think it was like an economic
collapse but i think
that there's still like some [ __ ] going
on please because there's still people
still work in the mines
people still take money although they
all take american dollars even though it
said in australia
so this was like actually a really
interesting movie and i'm surprised that
i didn't uh hear about it at the time
that it came out
yeah it's it's australian it has a lot
of
callbacks or shout outs to mad max one
so it's that kind of collapse movie i
would say
this may be happening around the time
of or 10 years after mad max 1
but not in not
in mad max 1 it's definitely the 70s or
early 80s
okay it's supposed to be a little bit
futuristic but you know how it is they
didn't have the money to really show the
future
you know true it's funny you see mad max
1 and you think it's
it's talking about the 70s it's clearly
supposed to be the future
so whoever wrote this knows
mad max of course it's an australian
[ __ ] you know
masterpiece and it's kind of
piggybacking along
with mad max one even though it's a lot
different than mad very different it's
almost kind of like
mad max meets the road yeah with like
some other kind of [ __ ] thrown in there
too it's a very bleak it's very
nihilistic
yeah well so was mad max one that's true
it's just that mad max 1 was a car guys
movie
yeah it was about cars and combat with
cars and societal collapse and the loss
of [ __ ]
government [ __ ] legitimacy you know
everything was kind of a sham
which that's really that's happening in
this movie there's a military
but it's kind of like a fake military
it doesn't really have the purpose
or not a legitimate purpose and that's
what that one scene was about where he
was asking that soldier
once they you know once he got captured
you know how is it he wakes up in the
morning you know what i mean
[ __ ] all this shit's really has no
meaning i mean
i don't want to make any spoils but you
know the dude had committed a serious
crime 10 years prior and he never even
got caught for it because
nobody gave a [ __ ] yeah it's that kind
of a moment the collapse was a societal
collapse
yeah it seemed like it seemed like they
were hinting that it was like an
economic collapse because like i said
there was still
gasoline there was still paper money
yeah there was still
um you know people running stores and
stuff well
societal collapse and economic collapses
are very
there's kind of a link yeah with that it
was a collapse
in the way that brazil collapsed when i
was there
yeah people still went to work and
everything but no one had any legitimacy
yeah it's kind of that guy okay the
government was illegitimate the police
were illegitimate
everything was [ __ ] illegitimate it
was just
a hollowed out shell or a zombie of what
it had been
20 years before yeah they're cops
but the cops were criminals and the
criminals were the ones kind of keep in
order
not really they were more like armed
militias it's it was that
kind of a collapse yeah the economy
collapses along with it because the
banks don't have any
any legitimacy and they just print
endless money so it's just paper
and he mentions that it's all just paper
just pepper said what did they use for
currency in the movie
but it had to be u.s right currency they
wouldn't take australian money they had
australian money
they had like people still had it but no
one would take it nobody would take
everybody said it has to be us dollars
right but then he he he he attacked that
idea too because he said well that's
just paper too
yeah so the collapse happened and it was
happening in america also
it's just that from the attack from the
australian perception
was is that american money was worth
more than australian money
but he was saying no it was equally
worthless
well i think too they were trying to
they imply it as well because some of
the characters like the character that
robert pattinson plays in this
is you know supposed to be from the
american south as was his brother
and then there were a lot of there was
like some chinese people in there there
were some other people so i think the
implication was that people had
come to australia to work in these mines
like they were gem mines or whatever
they were they they showed like a little
i feel like this movie there's a lot of
stuff going on
like around the perimeter of the movie
that it's like they don't really because
it's mostly
a character piece i mean guy pierce is
just this dude and his he just has this
quest
in the beginning like he's sitting in a
bar you know or what passes for a bar in
this
world and somebody steals his car which
is parked out front
and pretty much the entire film he's
just trying to get this car back you
don't know why
until the end and i don't want to spoil
that but
it's everything that happens like up to
then is
just like a byway on that
particular goal of him trying to get his
car back the reason why there's
america and china in it because
it's an amplification of the way
australians feel like they're caught in
between the chinese empire and the
american empire all right
and yeah there was immigration from both
of them this is like
a progression of of australian worries
from 2014 was in 2014 yeah that's when
this came out yeah
when this came out right it'd probably
be worse now with all the lockdowns and
everything
and what's going on with china but uh
the the if you guys play fallout
it's a lot like fall out to a certain
extent and mad max one
maybe it's not as progressed as fallout
in that video game it was a nuclear
apocalypse in an alternate timeline
this is this timeline it was not a
nuclear exchange but it was something
that
civilization collapsed it's it's uh its
legitimacy collapsed
yeah it still had economy but it was
it's implied that some of the economy is
based in slave labor too
just because you know there were slaves
in there if you didn't notice
they were they had sex slaves most of a
male
yeah or at least the one that they
showed so there may have not been very
many females
so that's kind of like calling out to a
boy and his dog
fierce in that movie a boy and his dog
yeah this had a little bit of a vibe
yeah too although not funny
no well boy his dog wasn't funny
either when you thought about it you
know the main character was don johnson
was running around trying to find women
to rape and kill
true he wasn't that funny he thought it
was funny well that's what i mean but i
just feel like the tone of this is like
a little bit different the tone of this
is more like
the road or like mad max like that it's
very very very blue yeah they were very
i don't think they showed any young
women as if they were kind of an
endangered species
i mean the one woman the one woman she
was kind of young
she was the doctor yeah but she was
hiding remember yeah
and then and she didn't accept money and
that's all she did was to be a doctor
and i think that
i don't think there were very many young
women around
um they didn't show them uh with
it was a collapsing population and a
collapsing
anyway the movie is basically
or the guy pierce and the movie itself
is a western
pretty much yeah is what it is it's kind
of like a weird western like anti-hero
yeah
guy pierce's character yeah i think his
name is eric yeah um
he's like not a good guy nobody is a
good guy kind of like the unforgiven
clint eastwood movie yeah called the
unforgiven yeah he's kind of like a
post-apocalyptic
version of that character i forgot what
clint eastwood's character was
he can shoot he knows guns but he's not
a gunslinger he's just a damn
rover yeah looking you guys like a rope
around i guess
but there's a play on words there with
dogs
you'll see what i'm talking about but
he's uh
uh he's uh
a moral survivor kind of kind of like a
dude who will survive at all costs
even though he doesn't really like it
but he survived yeah he doesn't like i
said this is definitely
i mean there's other characters in it
but honestly it's kind
it's guy pierce and robert pattinson
robert pattinson plays this dude named
ray or reynolds i think is his full name
and he's kind of um he's supposed to be
kind of a little slow
right yeah he is yeah and um so i guess
him and his brother and two other dudes
at the beginning
they were engaging in some illegal
activity i don't even know if you ever
figure out what it was i'm assuming it
was some kind of robbery or something
it had to do with those soldiers they
killed those soldiers yeah and like and
so
and so robert pattinson gets shot and
he's still alive but i guess his brother
and his fr
and the friends like leave him for dead
like the brother is kind of like hey we
have to go back and get him and they're
like yeah [ __ ] that
and these and the three guys they're the
ones that end up stealing guy pierce's
car
which kind of like you know leads to
that whole thing and then guy pierce
ends up coming across
robert pattinson's character and decides
he's gonna help him like take him to a
doctor or whatever because he figures
out that that dude the dude that stole
his car was his brother so he wants to
know where the brother is going and like
we have to go there and get my car back
and all this other stuff so i didn't
realize this until
i looked up this movie on wikipedia um
it was written and directed by david
micho he's the same guy that did um
[ __ ] man he did that other movie with
guy pierce because i think this is only
his second one what was it called
[ __ ] animals
animal kingdom that's right i haven't
seen that one either but i heard that
was also really good
and he co-wrote the story with joel
edgerton
and i was like joel edgerton is the same
guy that
who wrote directed and starred in that
movie uh the gift from 2015 the one
about like that creepy stalker dude
uh that was like really really good he
was also he's also an actor
he was in uh attack of the clones and
revenge of the sith he played young
uncle owen
you know uh he was that and he was also
in voya raced which we uh
saw at the theater he wrote and directed
that as well so he's kind of gets around
and as soon as i saw him i was like oh
yeah that guy i know that is
but yeah so he was the one that uh that
did that and this part was actually
written
uh for guy pierce specifically because
they had worked together before
and man this is i think i said this when
we were talking about the lighthouse
because robert pattinson was also in
that
and maybe this might have been
one of the first like kind of serious
roles that robert pattinson got after
like all that twilight debacle
that he was in and he actually came and
tried out for this role and they were
like really really impressed they're
like hey
um you know they just thought hey
twilight guy but
he can actually really act you know what
i mean which they felt which you know
they found out subsequently
later on because he was in like a bunch
of indie [ __ ] but
you know what i mean yeah what nothing
oh i thought you were gonna say them
no i guess the only thing i can say to
this is i guess uh the main character
and his little southern sidekick
if you know mad max lore real well
you'll see that basically what they've
done
is is they've kind of reversed some of
the stuff
but it is kind of you know in well it's
kind of an inversion of the situation
between max and the gyro captain
the um the the the little southern kid
who's slow
instead of is short instead of being
tall and intelligent
but he still has those same rotten teeth
and
the main character the guy pierces play
in is
kind of like mad max in a way with the
same
kind of similar problem with you know
dead
wife type issues but there's more to it
in this one
you'll see that they they inverted a lot
of stuff
it's kind of like an anti-version
of the relationship between max and the
java captain
yeah i mean all the way down to the
teeth and
certain ambushings and [ __ ] but things
are reversed
it you'll see what i mean if you know
that if you know a road warrior real
well
i mean this is like this is a pretty
interesting movie because like i said
there's not
a ton of dialogue in it and it's
kind of slow-moving and a lot of things
aren't explained um but
in a way i kind of liked that better
because it seemed like
as soon as it started you kind of really
got sucked into it because you were just
wondering what the [ __ ] was going on
and it just really kind of kept you in
suspense the whole time because you
weren't entirely sure
like you weren't entirely sure why guy
pierce wanted the car so bad
because he got another car like he stole
the other dude's car yeah and cars
evidently aren't valuable
yeah that's what i'm saying so it's not
like he needed it like to get around
which makes sense if you have a
collapsing population there'll be a lot
of cars laying around
and they had fuel uh but they didn't
have a lot of they didn't have a lot of
people driving
yeah it didn't would be like a gas
storage or anything like that yeah
and and you know there weren't a lot of
people driving so they had fuel you
could get it
they had ammunition you could get you
could buy it um
they had a lot of guns laying around
because you know
the military had collapsed it wasn't
around there there was a military but it
was like
okay a whole military base was three
guys
that's all that though
[Laughter]
and it didn't have much legitimacy to it
evidently um they were just kind of
going through the motions they didn't
really care much about the system they
were just being paid
um which they get into that it's a good
movie
it's a good movie it's um
it's mad max and the road warrior kind
of was a high energy movie this is the
opposite it's kind of low energy it's
weird
um yeah a lot of it it's a real it's a
character piece
yeah i mean essentially it's these two
guys
and sometimes they'll be like really
really long scenes where they're just
talking
or you know they're just kind of like
walking like in the
in the outback or whatever something
like that so
you know so don't think that it's gonna
be like it's it's not car company
yeah we keep saying that it's like mad
max but it's just in the time
kind of like tone or vibe of it it's not
really like mad max in the sense of
being an action movie
it's much more like a character drama i
like mad max
you know and i like a lot of the
post-apocalyptic movies that it
fit right in with them i knew what they
were doing it was
it was kind of doing a boy and his dog
and mad max but it was kind of a darker
tone to it
a little bit more modern it was a little
updated but it it did do a bunch of
callbacks to to those movies
um and you know guy pierce is great in
it he doesn't say much he but he's kind
of a
clint eastwood type character even
though he runs around just in shorts the
whole time i mean the way he's dressed
he does not look
stereotypical he's just a dude running
around his shorts yeah he's just got
like cargo shorts and like a button-up
shirt on like you would if you were in
the australian outback
yeah he's real [ __ ] scruffy looking
so there is any kind of like leather
outfits or anything you know
this is like uh it's a lot more
realistic yeah
well road warrior and beyond out of the
mad max
uh series is uh one it's being told to
you
in in in in a legendary form
as if it already happened a long time
ago right
and it's being told to you by tribal
people
okay and it's describing in road warrior
and beyond after that as other tribal
people
so you know i mean they're tribal motifs
to the way they're dressed
there weren't any textiles it was all
leather yeah
so who knows if the narrator is reliable
out of out of all the bad max's movies
you know what i mean you're being told
this by
savages yeah and i'm sure there's like
an element of myth making
yeah yeah you know what i mean at the
end of the movie there's always somebody
and this is what i remember back in the
old days you know
or something let's spice it up a little
bit yeah yeah
or you know what i mean in in fury road
it kind of it was
the whole movie was being was quoted
from a holy
book yeah about a road warrior
yeah so yeah this is kind of like the
wasteland version of jesus
yeah this is like i said this is a lot
more kind of realistic it has like a
western type of thing to it i've
i saw a couple reviewers compare it to
uh bone tomahawk a little bit
um just in the in the sense of it's real
violent but just in parts like a lot of
it is just kind of like character work
or characters having discussions
and then every now and then it'll be
like this really brutal violence usually
just like people getting shot randomly
like but like i said it's just
it's a more like realistic type of take
on it i guess
you know what i'm saying yeah there's
there's there's gunfights in it
but they're not glorified gunfights
they're they're just murder
yeah you know yeah which is the way they
actually are well yeah that's right
that's what i meant
by saying it was like realistic it's not
like oh no that character's dead it's
like people just walk up and like blam
you know yeah
without warning or sneaking up on them
while they're asleep uh
shoot them in the back you know [ __ ]
like that which is that's the dream of
[ __ ] commandos and delta force you
know you're attacking when they're
asleep
and when they're their weakest you know
that's why would you be attacking when
they're when they're at their strongest
your attack
trying yeah maximize enemy casualties
and minimize friendly casualties you
know so you
come in there [ __ ] 4 30 in the
morning while they're all taking a piss
or sleeping that's when you're gonna go
yeah
and you're gonna do it in the middle of
a [ __ ] rainstorm sure
yeah somebody asked how many live
streams are you doing same amount that
we do
uh every week yeah you know what i mean
we do one
i don't know how many do we do it a week
five four four or five weeks
i think we do five we're not doing any
next week because i'm going to be on
vacation but i but i we've recorded a
bunch of stuff that i'm going to put up
so there'll still be like stuff to watch
it just won't be
live and we'll and i'll be back for the
we're going to do the live stream
tonight
like or not tonight friday night like we
usually would and
we'll do the live stream the following
friday because i'll be back by then
so i'm not gonna miss any of the main
shows just like the side tracks and
stuff like that
so yeah this is actually if you like a
lot of a24 stuff if you like kind of
dystopian stuff like western kind of
stuff
like i said it's not an action movie um
it's real violent it's
like character based uh real bleak real
nihilistic
and kind of slow moving but that
that's not a bad thing it's not really
that slow moving it's
not really like a lot of [ __ ] happens
yeah think about it
it's just it doesn't come across as a as
a real high-energy movie but there's a
bunch of [ __ ] happening in it
it's like a western but it's very
australian
yeah it's good it won a bunch of awards
like in australia when they
showed it over there but didn't make a
[ __ ] ton of money but made more than i
than a movie like this would normally
make kind of getting a lot of respect
for that a24
they make some good [ __ ] yeah it's been
pretty good i mean they kind of little
indie company huh
yeah i mean their their shit's kind of
diverse because i think grant there's
hammer pointed out earlier and i've
forgotten about this but a24 put out
that uh spring breakers movie too so
they
said they'd do like movies like that as
well it was good so it had a bunch of
boobs in it
well yeah and then that's i don't have
to just and that's tom's
mark of quality i have to [ __ ] judge
that i heard
[Laughter]
magnify boobs yeah
c cups become double e cups
you got to patent those and sell them
yeah
no i'm not going to [ __ ] sell them
actually i'm just going gonna i'm gonna
run up i'm gonna lease them out
[Laughter]
kind of like uh uh howard hughes dad did
with tool code
he had um making drill bits that could
get down to where the good oil was
yeah yeah yeah you don't sell them you
lisa
so you make all the money pat didn't
lease them yeah yeah
he made it all morning you see he was
like pretty smart yeah
yeah oh my god all right uh do we have
anything else we need
how long have we been going on i don't
even know like my my [ __ ] thing is
all
messed up okay so 31 minutes that's not
too bad
yeah because we have to we probably
won't we'll go on too much like what are
you doing oh
okay is it working
hammer said spring breakers should be
high on your list of movies to review
yeah
check that out i mean most of like
pretty much every a24 movie i've seen
i've liked like i said everybody knows
like the big
you know the big hitters like hereditary
and midsummer and all those but
they've made a bunch of and there's some
movies i just keep forgetting that it
was a24 i had totally forgotten that
tusk was put out by a24
yeah so like i said they're kind of all
over the map honestly
they do but they mostly do a lot of they
just do a lot of indie [ __ ] which you
know that's good
tom you look cool however being english
i'm getting that goth leads feeling
i'm ready to go back to lead to hang out
with [ __ ] andrew
yeah uh oh yeah great oh that's right
that's right spring breakers was
directed by harmony karine he was the
same guy that
that was the same person that did um
what was that [ __ ]
movie the beach bum remember that we saw
in the theater that was fun yeah that's
the same director
okay and check it out that was a weird
ass movie well that was a good movie but
it was like weird
i remember we went and saw that in
theater i think we were the only people
in there
yeah i liked it though we should have
been smoking in there
yeah probably drop it acid
drinking at least yeah see we never
really i mean a couple of times when we
went to movies like in the
in the fancy theater yeah um a couple
times because you know amc's had the
bar yeah so you could get cocktails but
they're kind of expensive they're
expensive and they're weak yeah they
don't make it really weak
i like that they have like little themed
ones for whatever the movies are coming
out but yeah they don't pour them like
super well because they don't want a
bunch of people running around like
maniacs in the [ __ ] movie theater
people are like messy enough as it is
when they're sober for great sake
messy enough and loud enough it's like
yeah let's not add
alcohol on top of that buzz yeah poor
people that work there and be like oh
how to clean up all kind of crap people
will be
jumping off [ __ ] ceiling like
chimpanzees you know what i mean
if you like a video please uh like share
and subscribe
yeah yeah but yeah so this was uh kind
of just a random choice and
like i said it just it totally
piggybacked off of
seeing tusk because yeah it was one of
the trailers that was on tusk of all
things even though it's absolutely
nothing like tusk at all
right but i guess like i said so it was
the same studio check it out you can
get it for 2.99 i think on amazon you
can rent it for 2.99 yeah i think it was
100 either 299 or 399 it's worth it
yeah so like i said if you like that
kind of thing then uh if you like
dystopian kind of movies
and uh you've seen some of the other and
like i said that this director also did
another movie with guy pierce which is
called animal kingdom which is also
supposed to be really good like they
came up before this one
um so probably i'll have to go watch
that one too
um but yeah so you have anything else
you want to say
what are y'all's big vacation plans i'm
just going on vacation yeah it's just
her
it's just me i'm hey i'm staying here
he's gonna take care of you
he's gonna take care of pokey yeah i'm
just i'm not going very
far i'm only going to st augustine yeah
um which is only about an hour hour and
20 minutes from here
she's been in this office for five
[ __ ] years man
pretty much sent her on vacation i
haven't had a day off
well because i work pretty much every
day other than the only times i take a
day off is thanksgiving
day and christmas day yeah other than
because everyone else is off too
but i don't get weekends off or anything
like that because she's a writer man
she's got to get out of here and [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] you know what i mean yeah
get away from this [ __ ] then she'll come
back
yeah i'm just going for like five days
yeah i'm just gonna go to a bunch of
museums either like go to
see some alligators and yep [ __ ] like
that walk around
eat a lot yeah it'll be fun
gramsci is asking tom and jenny not chad
oh well that's all right everybody can
answer it's an open question
all right so it's tuesday today right
isn't it okay
so it's tuesday today which means that
tomorrow night is the side tracks party
stream
so we're just gonna have to like drink
man i need some sleep yo it's like i
i woke up at three in the [ __ ]
morning i think it was i don't even
think
it was three yet i think it was like
quarter to three and i could not get
back to sleep
so finally it was just like 6 a.m and
the sun was up i was like [ __ ] it i
guess i'm getting up
so when you're getting off work today uh
well
we still we have to record one more
thing right
and i have to edit it but then after
that we can and then we gotta we just
gotta watch one movie tonight that we
gotta
record a thing tomorrow and then we'll
be all caught up and we'll have extra
[ __ ] for everybody to watch while i'm
gone
yeah because i wanted everybody to have
something every day to watch even though
we weren't live streaming every day okay
let's get on this next one
okay so we will see you guys tomorrow
evening at 5 pm for the side tracks
party stream so get your
cocktails or whatever your drinking
choices ready 5 pm our time
yeah eastern standard time so we will
see you guys
then thanks for dropping bye